[Music]
the noble consciousness that is not
related here to the object as an essence
in general on the contrary what is alien
to it is its own being for self it finds
confronting in its own but alienated
self as such in the shape of an
objective fixed reality which it has to
receive from another fixed being for
self its object is a being for self that
is its own being for self but because it
is an object it is at the same time it's
so facto an alien reality which he has
its own being for self which has a will
of its own that is it sees self in the
power of an alien will on which it is
dependent for possession of its own self
paragraph 516 is nice and short and
actually is is pretty straightforward
there is some important stuff going on
but but I think it's fairly easy to get
through and to understand it's really
about the noble consciousness and its
alienation from itself as we're gonna
see play itself out in in the paragraphs
yet to come now in terms of wealth as
opposed to the the state power and he's
not actually going to use this term and
I'm doing that I have on the board here
alienation and said he's going to use
part of it friend
meaning alien foreign you know and he's
going to talk about an alien will and
and finding one's own being for self
alien to oneself so he says that the
noble consciousness is not related to
the object of the gig in stock right
that which stands opposed to it it's not
related to it as an essence in general
and the reason that I put wealth here is
because in the last few paragraphs we
have made this transition to what shows
itself as essence that is wealth right
and so it's not relating itself at this
point directly to wealth instead the
noble consciousness is attempting to
make sense of itself and we saw that the
noble consciousness really has two sides
the side that is is engaged in service
that receives honor there's a sort of
transaction and identification with the
state power there and at that side now
finds its own being for self its other
Ness its irreducible individuality being
given to it as an object and here's
where things start to get really strange
because up until this point it's been
the noble consciousness holding out this
part of itself it's being for self as a
kind of stubborn you know recess that it
could keep entirely to itself even while
it's engaging in service this is how the
ignoble consciousness is already there
at the core
noble consciousness now instead what we
have been assuming is really the most
inward we're finding to be in a certain
sense the most outward to the noble
consciousness it's conscious of its own
self as being something alien to it it
could ask itself what is going on here
Who am I in relation to who I thought I
was so he says on the contrary what is
alien tram dit - it is its own being for
self it finds confronting it its own but
alienated again rammed self as such and
he says in the shape of an objective gig
and Stan Lika fixed reality festive your
kite something that that remains the
same and this is a little strange here
because when we think of being for self
we tend to think of fluidity we tend to
think of negativity we tend to think of
of this reflexive relation not as being
something that almost sounds in itself a
fixed reality right but that's what
Hegel is saying here it finds this
confronting yet and here's where it gets
very interesting an objective fixed
reality which it has to receive from
another fixed being for self so where is
this other being for self arising where
are we going to find it is it from the
state power is it from the unlimited or
absolute monarch no in this case it
turns out that it is coming from wealth
or perhaps the rich we have the the
introduction of a new element here which
also is for itself and Hegel will talk
about this here as being an alien
reality which has its own being for self
right it has a will of its own but it
sees itself in the power of an alien
will on which it is dependent for
possession of its own self so that's
that's how the passage ends so what do
we actually have here the noble
consciousness becomes cognizant of how
in its own being for itself it is
it is no longer just within the relation
of itself to the - you know what
constitutes that is noble that is to the
state power its existing as part of the
economy its existing in relation to
benefactors its existing in relation to
another will
self-consciousness can make abstraction
from every particular aspect and for
that reason even when it is time to one
of them it retains the recognition and
intrinsic validity of itself as an
independent being here however as
regards the aspect of that purity is
it's very own that is its own eye it
finds it as it is outside of itself and
belongs to another finds its personality
is such dependent on the contingent
personality of another on the accident
of a moment on a Caprice or some other
utterly unimportant circumstance in the
sphere of law what is in the power of an
objective being appears as a contingent
content from which it is possible to
make abstraction and the controlling
power does not affect the self as such
or on the contrary the self is
acknowledged here however the self sees
itself certainty as such to be
completely devoid of essence sees that
it's pure personality is absolutely not
a personality the spirit of its
gratitude is therefore the feeling of
the most profound dejection as well as
of extreme rebellion when the pure eye
beholds itself outside of itself and
rent asunder that everything that has
continuity and universality everything
that is called law good and right it is
at the same time rent asunder it is
destroyed all identity dissolves away
for the utmost disparity now occupies
the scene what is absolutely essential
is now absolutely unofficial being for
self is now external to itself the pure
eye itself is absolutely disrupted
paragraph 517 is longer than the
preceding paragraph it really the
preceding paragraphs and there's a bit
more going on there but it's really
connected to the same themes this this
fundamental split within self
consciousness no longer the noble
consciousness as such but now self
consciousness because remember the
distinction between the noble and the
base consciousness has been eroded in
the process of the dialectic there is
this split going out and why is that the
case Hegel tells us that
self-consciousness can make abstraction
from every particular aspect and for
that reason even when it is tied to one
of them it retains the recognition and
intrinsic reality of itself as an
independent being this is one aspect of
it of its being for itself it can
recognize itself as an independent being
it can say I am still Who I am
regardless of what circumstances I fall
into regardless of whatever other people
say regardless of what my condition is I
am who I choose to be now at the same
time he says as regards the aspect of
that pure actuality which is it's very
own that is its own I it finds that this
is outside of itself not only is there
an alienation going on here but notice
what Hegel says next it finds itself
outside of itself and belongs to another
and I've done a little bit playing on
words here right and other it belongs to
the other and who is the other somebody
else who is not the self now why with
self consciousness belong to the other
well remember here that we are still
dealing with this dialectic of wealth
and state power and we're now looking at
the side of wealth what is it that
wealth affords to us the possibility for
enjoyment and satisfaction but more than
that the possibility of being
wealth is needed to purchase what allows
us not only to live a bare life of food
and drink shelter some measure of safety
but all the other things that allow us
to have our our self-image are who we
are so he goes on and he says it finds
that it belongs to another it finds its
personality as such dependent on the
contingent personality of another now
why should that be the case well I mean
let's think of some examples here and
all we need to do is pick a few and this
will really drive the point home I'll
take one that's particularly close to
home why is it that I would create these
videos well it's because I want to
explain Hegel and make all that well
that's dependent on even having the
apparatus see we can say infrastructure
of the internet that makes any of this
feasible I mean when I first started
reading Hegel that's not what I was
thinking about you know the Internet I
suppose was was coming into vogue to
some degree but it certainly didn't have
the hold upon our life it had not
permeated actuality quite so much to
where virtuality and actuality have
become almost completely blurred
together it's because of something
contingent right and then why did I
start doing Hegel in the first place
well you know my my youtube viewers I
took a poll and they said we want Hegel
and Sartre and Heidegger and Mark who'sa
I never actually did shoot any videos on
maracuja started shooting the
existentialism videos and then I started
thinking maybe I should start shooting
some things on on Hegel and it was a
rather kick sonic Enterprise I mean
Hegel is not the most popular
philosopher right but it was feasible
and at a certain point it took out a
kind of life of its own in which I am
accountable not only to myself but to a
whole bunch of others my viewers my
subscribers the people who fund this
project on patreon think about all sorts
of other aspects where people say well
why why did you do the job that you do
well it happened to be the one that paid
the best at the time of the actuality
that I am in order to maintain the
independence the actuality demanded that
I wear this uniform that I behave in
this way that I clock in at this time
that I work from home that and we go on
and on and on and on there's so many
cases where a person could have done so
many different things if economic
conditions it not even just economic
conditions if the personality of the
people who make the decisions or who pay
them or purchase things from them we're
a little bit different that is
contingency that is what Hegel calls
accident do fall right that is Caprice
bilker this is a really interesting
thing to point out the other is not this
totally fixed you know oppressive
monolithic thing it's all those people
from whom we at this point derive this
bit of our sustenance or our you know
way of supporting ourself at another
time this the people who fund the people
who purchase the people who bankroll the
people who organize all this sort of
stuff so he goes on and he says the
contingent personality of another the
accident of a moment or a Caprice or
some other utterly unimportant
circumstance there's a certain sense
here
of when Hegel brings up you know
contingency caprice that sort of thing
of things not mattering so much anymore
or not having the meaning that they did
a kind of desperation or despair raises
its head and may in fact set in so he
goes on and he says in the sphere of law
this is by contrast he's not saying that
this is the sphere of law he's wanting
to give us a contrast to what was
discussed earlier on in the reason
section or in the spirit section in the
very first part in the sphere of law
what is in the power of an objective
being appears as a contingent content
from which it is possible to make
abstraction the controlling power does
not affect the self as such right we
when we're related to each other in in
terms of law we have sort of an outer
shell and we relate ourselves to each
other that way but the inner shell
remains an independent being throughout
all the transformations that's not the
case here that's something different
in this paragraph he says here the self
sees itself certainty as such to be
completely devoid of essence it no
longer knows exactly who and thereby
what it is and is it going to identify
itself with its contingent relation to
other economic beings if it does that
that could change that seems very
arbitrary so he goes on and he says what
happens it sees that it's pure
personality is absolutely not a
personality this is a deep alienation
that Hegel is talking about here so he
goes on and he talks about the spirit of
its gratitude why is it showing
gratitude it's showing gratitude for the
fact that the other is providing it with
its economic place its purpose its
satisfactions it shows gratitude but
that angle says this gratitude is sort
of a
affected with something else he says the
feeling of gratitude is the feeling of
the most profound dejection as well as
extreme rebellion
nobody likes feeling themselves in the
debt of others feeling dependent upon
them gratitude sometimes contains
dejection looking down feeling like
somebody else has to help me out I don't
have what I need or rebellion you son of
a [ __ ] you harnessed me you made me do
what you want
I'll show you gratitude but it's not
gonna be real gratitude it's gonna be
grudging it's going to have some sort of
sting concealed in it these are two
possibilities for a self that is in the
process of dissolution we're not really
talking about the noble consciousness
here anymore are we
so Hegel goes on and he says when the
pure I behold itself outside of itself
and rent asunder right when it's going
to be holt when the pure I be holds the
eye that is actuality in relation to the
other in relation to wealth what happens
everything that has continuity and
university allottee everything that is
called law everything that is good
everything that is right
Hegel says is destroyed is rent asunder
is torn apart this is the the breakdown
not only of the individual but of the
world of the individual the moral world
of the individual so he says all
identity dissolves away for the utmost
disparity now occupies the scene
what is this absolutely essential turns
out to be honest enchilada itself the
pure RI itself is absolutely disrupted
what does this start to sound like have
we seen this
shape of consciousness before does this
sound perhaps remotely like what was
going on in oh I don't know the
master-slave dialectic with the breakup
of the slave and his or her personality
and the reformation of it or does this
sound more like what was happening in
the skepticism part of Stoicism
skepticism and the unhappy consciousness
or looking ahead does this sound more
like the world of law and the lord of
the world well it's it's like all of
them except it's going a bit further now
this shake-up is going deeper it's more
concrete
therefore all of the oldest
consciousness receives back from riches
the objectivity of its being for self
and supersedes it it is not only like
the preceding reflection incomplete in
principle but is conscious of not being
satisfied the reflection in which the
self receives itself is something
objective - it is thus a direct
contradiction lodged in the pure eye
itself qua self however it stands at the
same time directly above this
contradiction it is absolutely elastic
and therefore again supersedes this
supersession of it self rejects this
disowning of itself which would make its
being for self into something alien and
rebels against this reception of itself
and in this very reception is conscious
of itself
paragraph 518 might come as somewhat of
a surprise given what the trajectory has
seemed to be in the previous paragraphs
where first the noble consciousness have
gotten revealed is not really being the
noble consciousness because there's
stuff going on in there that doesn't
really seem all that noble this is being
for self and then we get self
consciousness and it turns out that it's
contingent on another and that that
other really turns out to be wealth
write them here translated as riches but
the self-consciousness is going to have
the last laugh here and Hegel is going
to talk in very interesting terms about
what we might call an elf a bong a a sub
Latian a a transcendence on a higher
level because it's involving its own
reflexivity
it is quite literally an elf table of
alcohol designs right with the the being
while the superseding the super session
of the self the having been superseded
of the self this sounds really abstract
you might say what what is he talking
about there well what we're finding
going on here is what Hegel is is called
at other points determinate negation
this process of the negation of the
negation yielding us something positive
but something new not merely the same
you know starting point but a
transformed one so he says although this
consciousness receives back from riches
the objectivity of its being for self
right which is nice it gets as we've
seen riches gives the being for self
which is outside of itself it then
transcends that or supersedes it it you
know it engages in this process of
sublation and incorporates it back to
itself or it also says well it doesn't
really matter I'm still the
but we saw that the self was in the
previous passage sort of broke apart all
certainty was lost all identity was lost
yet it's going to come back now so he
says it is not only like the preceding
reflection incomplete in principle but
is conscious
what is its consciousness of not being
satisfied the reflection he says in
which the self receives itself is
something objective is a direct
contradiction lodged in the pure eye
itself a contradiction of Vitas Brook a
you know contradiction no longer just a
opposition but a fundamental things
being at odds with each other as we saw
in the previous paragraph but now Hegel
says that enables us to move past that
he says qua self it stands at the same
time directly above this contradiction
it realizes the contradiction within
itself but it realizes that it's still
there
realizing this contradiction that
there's you might say if we want to talk
in meteorological terms there is an eye
to the center of the storm play on words
there right because we're talking about
the eye that says I the the eye of
identity so he says it's absolutely
elastic and thereby by being absolutely
elastic by being willing to depart from
its old self and take on a new self it
supersedes the supersession of self
it raises out Haven to another level all
right so he says it rejects this
disowning of itself which would make its
being for herself into something alien
that's what was happening in the
previous paragraph it's being for self
was turned into something alien
something foreign to it so he says and
it rebels against this reception of
itself in this very reception
it is conscious of itself it becomes
conscious of who it is no longer is the
old self no longer is the self that's
being just given to it arbitrarily but
as a self that is actually in revolt a
self that is not yet sure of who or what
or even where it is but who says no I am
something not just what you make of me
and not just what you know contingency
or arbitrariness would throw in my lap I
still can't say Who I am but I know that
there is an eye
you